you are used to doing harrowing subjects
you did the Mexican drug cartel when you
did American healthcare what was it
about this how did these guys catch our
attention and how did you commit to and
pursue this doc so yeah I was traveling
around the world with my last term
cartel and and that was sort of started
reading voraciously about what was
happening with Isis and trying to see if
there's a film to be made and eventually
I came across this article by David
Remnick in The New Yorker about this
group rapids being slaughtered silently
and just right when I read it I knew
that that is my way into this story I
reached out to the guys and you know for
me these were large amorphous sort of
complex subjects that that we as sort of
citizens often keep it at arm's length
you know I think they're so often
relegated to headlines into stats into
photos and I really really wanted to try
to put a sort of human face to these
topics and to try to allow you as
audience members to go on this very
visceral journey to hopefully have a
little bit better understanding of
what's I guess first and foremost
happening in Raqqa happening in Syria
and then I guess in a larger sense sort
of the immigrant experience that these
guys were forced into are these how did
Matt approach you and what was it about
his charming personality that made you
decide to work with him on this yes so
it was our first visit to us and it
happened to be with the two of my
colleagues and I in in DC and we came to
receive International Press Freedom
Award from CB J and we had that crazy
schedule we got an email from one of the
organizers told us that there is a movie
director wanna see us and we had two
hours like as a perk and we were so
tired we understand we said we're tired
we wanna sleep and they said no come you
need to come and then we went and you're
planning not to do any movie or anything
for security reasons but we got there
thought that we're gonna meet movie
director who speak about Steven
Spielberg was coming know like I thought
like I wonder unexplained 50 years doing
movies and then we had met and then we
watched the trailer of documentary
Carter land and after that we said our
Wow is professional so it took us like
couple of days to talk between at the
talk to discuss ooh either to do the
movie or not and the security issue was
dementing but at the same time we knew
that making this documentary will help
us to get our message out to educate our
people for thousands and even millions
of people around the world about what's
going on in Syria and rock so and that
was one of the main reason why we
started our organization so we decided
that we will make this movie even if it
will increase the level of risk and and
that for you obviously are there ethical
questions like that that you when we
exposed them further you tell their
story but you also expose them to
further danger so how did you navigate
those concerns as a filmmaker yeah I
mean their safety was paramount at every
step along the way and I think from the
very beginning from those first
conversations as you said it's very
forthright with with two things one the
type of films that I want to make the
type of film that I wanted to make you
know I want to make a very intimate film
and now required being with them for not
weeks not days but for months and the
ramifications of what what that meant
but also the ramifications of now that
the film is being released publicly that
inevitably their threat profile will
increase and you know are you okay with
that I think you know Aziz and his
colleagues wanted to come out from
behind the veneer social media you know
Aziz was already sort of the face of the
group the other guys were known and so I
think they wanted to show that their
modern Muslim meant that they're you
know real guys from Raqqa they're not
avatars and that you know they wanted
their their faces and their story retold
despite the risk obviously Matt security
to shape in a paramount sense what you
did looking out for these guys so how
did it influence the making of this film
and the editing in particular having
that uppermost in your mind yeah I mean
there's a complete complete complete
different experience than the last some
cartel and where I was completely you
know on the front line to this you know
quote-unquote battle between these
vigilantes and the Mexican drug cartels
and I was very much out in the open very
much in physical danger very much you
know in shootouts and meth labs and
torture chambers with this film I was
the sort of fear and experience was much
different I was you know for the most
part boxed in in these safe houses and
and and with these guys who spent most
of their time behind computers and cell
phones and so I think the hardest thing
for me I guess two things I guess first
just the logistics of filming the sort
of how when and where the producing side
of it was very very hard
I'm just because they were you know in
different places they didn't necessarily
want to communicate you know we had to
communicate to encrypted means and so
just the logistics of getting there and
being there was it was quite difficult
but then once I was there is also quite
difficult to try to find the drama in
the cinema with what for the most part
was just people sitting around and so I
you know that was the most of a ban
someone who's both directing and
shooting producing this was was trying
to really capture the humanity in the
cinema and the drama with these very
constrained situation at the
claustrophobia was part of the story no
closer probably was absolutely part of
the story I seized what do you hope the
impact of this movie is going to be yes
look too good to be one or like be aware
about what's going on in Syria so many
people they've been saying that art is
far away since zero and zero what we've
la cacica
has been everywhere luck with that
that's in Europe in us so to alert them
about what's going on in Raqqa
specifically in Syria and general like
to tip the stove
or frog up evil so millions of people
who were living there and they were like
voiceless and we decided to be their
voice so many people they had an idea
that all the Syrians or that we were
frog are terrorists but we are not so we
didn't decide that we want to have Isis
they came and they make you bite at our
country our city so we wanted to show
the reality of what's going on so to let
the people understand what's going on -
shirt - let them watch shirt that was
with their friend their relatives and
then at least luck would be we'll be
able to have education between the
people because all the problems around
the world is because because of dollars
of the education so having people you
can't it about what's going on it will
help us and to help everyone to get out
from all these troubles and conflict
problems maybe one world would change
something maybe from mouth to mouth from
person to person to talk to some
governments power leaders politicians
who will be able to do a real change and
stop discomfort and one last thing I'll
say about that I mean I think for me the
term is also an homage to journalism and
amage to people who are out there
fighting for the truth and seeking the
truth especially in this world where
truth seems to be malleable I think it's
so important and we are relying as
citizens and more and more on people
like Aziz who are shedding light on dark
corners of the world so I hope that that
you know if you all believe in what
they're doing if audiences believe what
they're doing that they support groups
like Aziz support groups like the
community to protect journalists who are
who are advocating and fighting for for
citizens around the world who are again
shedding light on places that we would
have otherwise no idea what's happening
won't you please thank Abdulaziz Al
Hamza and Matt Hyneman